- Sorry Goose, but it's
time to buzz the tower.
(jet engine whirring)
- All right, that seems super bad.
- Yeah, as Maverick's defense attorney,
I've gotta say he needs to, at this point,
not say anything to anyone
about what just happened,
lock himself into a room
and hope for the best.
- We're gonna have a good time.
(bottle clinks)
- Always.
- There's a new "Top
Gun", which reminded me,
they broke a whole bunch of
laws in the original movie,
but to talk about all the military law
that Maverick and Goose broke,
I needed some help.
So I called in some
air support, my friend,
the lawyer and former
Major in the Marines,
the scowl owl to my legal Eagle, Spencer.
Spencer, thanks for coming.
- Happy to be here, Devin.
- So apparently everyone on the internet
is an expert in military law,
but what makes you qualified
to talk about all of the
broken laws in "Top Gun"?
- I was a judge advocate
in the Marine Corps
where I prosecuted people,
including on Marine
Corps Air Base, Miramar,
which is where "Top Gun" was actually set.
I was also an artillery officer
and a joint terminal attack controller.
I did that in Iraq, where I
was calling in airstrikes.
And what that means is I was
working with pilots to my left,
to my right and above me.
And I saw the good, the bad and the ugly.
And now I'm a deputy district attorney
in the Pacific Northwest
where I prosecute major felony crimes.
- All right, internet,
a real former marine
has entered the chat, so beware.
- Devin, I've got the need.
- The need for speed?
- No, the need to put some pilots in jail.
- (laughing) All right, let's dig in.
(jet engine whirring)
- [Pilot] Whew, he's
never (indistinct) before.
- [Commander] What the
hell are they doing there?
- You know, it's a minor detail,
but there's no actual
such thing as a MiG-28.
- Really, there's no MiG-28?
That sounds like a real thing.
- We happen to see a MiG-28,
do a 4G negative dive.
- No, there's actually a MiG-29,
but I think they just subtracted one
for this film for some reason.
- The MiG-28?
- Oh, okay, so what are the
planes they're standing in for?
Well, whatever bad guy is
antagonizing the Americans here.
- The MiG-28?
- Those are actually F-5's
that have been painted black
and they add that little
red star on the tail.
- [Devin] Aha, interesting.
- You know, fun fact,
they actually never identify who the enemy
or the opposition is in this entire movie.
And we know for a fact
that it's the same one
at the beginning and at the end.
It's just the opposite side, the bad side.
We don't know.
- Ah.
- [Pilot] This is Ghostrider 117.
This bogey's all over me.
He's got missile locked on me.
Do I have permission to fire?
- Do not fire until fired upon.
- So this is an odd situation.
It's not unusual for there to
be tension between militaries
where the governments aren't
exactly friendly to each other.
I mean, we have to understand this film
as we are not at war
with this other country.
This is the Cold War.
There are tensions.
But we're not actually in a shooting war.
The problem is the second
that anyone shoots,
the other person gets to shoot back.
In the law of war,
self-defense is always
available to a party.
So the pilot here is actually
making the right choice.
We're not gonna start the war.
And whoever that commander is, is saying,
you don't get to shoot
until you're fired upon
because the US doesn't
wanna start this firing war.
Yeah and anyone who's in the military,
who's gonna be going into
either direct combat operations
or close to combat operations,
they're gonna be advised
on all sorts of rules of engagement,
what they're allowed to do,
what kind of permission
they have to get to engage.
But one thing that every
single soldier, marine,
sailor is taught before
going on a deployment is
you are allowed to act in self-defense.
You just have to use your judgment
and be real careful before
you start a shooting war
with someone that we're
not in a shooting war with.
(jet engine whirring)
- [Goose] Is this your idea of fun, Mav?
- [Maverick] Greetings. (laughing)
(upbeat music)
- [Goose] Watch the birdie.
- Okay, now I'm just a
humble, country lawyer here.
But it seems to me that
if an F-14 was inverted
on top of an F-5,
that the tail wings would
absolutely smack each other.
And I mean, even if they weren't, somehow,
that seems like such an
inherently dangerous thing, that,
if I was the commanding
officer of these pilots,
I would not want them to go inverted
because if they crashed,
they would've started a
complete international incident.
That seems like a really bad idea.
- I mean, this is the kind of behavior,
which is so Hollywood,
but they're committing a crime right now.
(Devin laughing)
Oddly enough, they're committing a crime.
As cool as it is,
the crime is improperly
hazarding an aircraft.
And the reality of that crime
is that in time of war,
you could get the death penalty for that.
- Yes, sir.
- But admittedly, looks cool as hell.
- Well, and that's rule number one.
Rule number one in the
military is look cool.
- Trouble
- Come on, man.
We're get low on gas.
Let's land this sucker.
(machine beeping)
(mechanical clanking)
(jet engine whirring)
- Goddamn it!
(Spencer sighs)
- Okay, so is the instruction
to land, is that an order?
Did he disobey an order to go up
and help a fellow pilot?
Also, I don't know how
you help another pilot
from another plane, but
that's a separate issue.
- You know, he's committing
at least two different crimes right now.
He's willfully disobeying an order
from a superior commissioned officer.
- To land, that plane that's an order!
- He's instructed the land.
He's gotta land.
He's also improperly
hazarding an aircraft.
The fuel is low and he's
going off to do something,
apparently give moral support to-
- [Devin] Yeah, moral support.
- I don't know if he's planning
on ejecting from his plane,
into the other plane
to give maybe a back rub
and like help out his buddy,
but either way, it's not looking good.
- So you're saying,
it's not standard operating
procedure to fly a plane
without fuel to try and give
moral support to a pilot
who seems to be under the
weather for some reason?
- You know, that's generally frowned upon.
Yeah.
- Okay.
("Danger Zone" by Kenny Loggins)
♪ Highway to the danger zone ♪
Okay, so I know this one,
Tom Cruise is driving a motorcycle
very fast, in California,
with no helmet on whatsoever.
That is a violation of
California's vehicular code.
It might be petty, but it's a $250 fine,
and or a year of probation.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
And I mean, these pilots are probably
radioing into the tower saying,
who the hell is this random guy
driving his motorcycle
along the flight line,
shaking his fist at us?
I'd get an investigation, at least.
- And also as someone
who rides a motorcycle,
I can't fathom riding without a helmet.
I know there are some states
that you can ride a
motorcycle without a helmet.
First of all, it's dangerous
enough without a helmet.
Like you should wear a helmet
because the injuries of people
that don't wear a helmet
are gruesome and grotesque.
But also, if you're riding really fast,
there's so much wind,
your aviator sunglasses
don't do that much.
So if you value your life,
please wear a helmet while
you ride a motorcycle,
whether it's in California
or anywhere else, please.
- I'm Charlotte Blackwood.
- I'm Maverick.
- Maverick?
Does your mother not
like you or something?
- No, it's my call sign.
- Okay, that is so cringe.
That is so, so cringe.
You just don't do that.
That is the biggest
dork move in the world.
- What's going on here?
- He's introducing himself
by his call sign to-
- Oh! (laughing)
- I mean, that is so cringe,
but it's also unrealistic.
And the reason it's
unrealistic is because no one,
no one has a cool call sign like that.
Maverick, Iceman, you don't
get call signs like that.
Every call sign is gonna be
something unique and weird
about you or something that you did,
which is borderline
embarrassing/humiliating.
If you were to go into a place and say,
I want my call sign to be Maverick,
you would probably be hazed
to the point of death.
(door squeaking)
(upbeat pop music)
(bell chiming)
Don't do this.
- But they had a connection.
- So, eh, I have no
doubt in Maverick's mind
that he has a special
connection with this lady
and that this was an
invitation with her eyes,
for him to come join
her in the ladies' room.
Let me put it this way.
He's probably breaking
at least three laws here.
Let's assume for a second
that this poor woman
had no intention of inviting
Maverick into the ladies' room.
- [Devin] I think that's
probably safe to say, yeah.
- Yeah, so he's basically committing
a couple different crimes.
One, conduct unbecoming
an officer or gentleman.
This is so basic.
That is literally the text of the statute,
conduct unbecoming, an
officer or a gentleman.
All it requires to show is
that he's doing something
indecent, immoral,
something wrong.
It's also probably prejudicial
to good order and discipline,
or has a tendency to
discredit the Armed Forces,
which is a violation of Article 134
of the Uniformed Code of Military Justice.
- Yeah, well, it sounds bad
when you put it that way.
- I mean, he's in uniform, on base.
This kind of behavior is
really dangerous for him.
- She has a PhD in astrophysics
and she's also a civilian contractor.
So you do not salute her,
but you better listen to her
because the Pentagon listens
to her about your proficiency.
It's all yours, Charlie.
- Thank you.
Hello?
- Okay, so is it at all realistic
that there would be a civilian who
is some sort of contractor
that would be providing some instruction
to the pilots at Top Gun?
- I don't think it's unusual
or I don't think it's so
unusual that it's unrealistic.
We have civilian contractors
everywhere in the military
doing a wide variety of things
and especially people who
have specific training
and experience like having
a PhD in astrophysics.
I'm sure that they could
be useful to some extent,
probably not talking about tactics,
but talking about the
aerodynamics of the aircraft,
things like that.
- I'm not sure that astrophysics
would help with aerodynamics.
I think-
- Was it astrophysics?
- PhD in astrophysics?
- They said, yeah, they said astrophysics.
So unless they're charting with the stars,
I'm not sure her PhD is
gonna help that much.
I guess we're assuming that she has
a bunch of other experience
in the private sector
that led her to this expertise.
- Well, you know, it
is possible, I suppose,
that "Top Gun 2" is
actually gonna be in space.
- Yes!
Yes.
(Spencer laughing)
In space.
(electronic whirring)
- Welcome to the
danger zone.
- That's classified.
- It's what?
- It's classified.
I could tell you, but
then I'd have to kill you.
- Lieutenant, I have top secret clearance.
The Pentagon sees to it
that I know more than you.
- Yeah, okay.
So, (laughs) I've never
been in the military,
but I do have a lot of friends
who have TS/SCI clearance
and she might have that kind of clearance,
but none of them necessarily
have TS/SCI, right.
Like, I don't think all of those pilots
are necessarily gonna have the clearance
to be able to hear what,
he just said, he can't tell people
without that particular clearance.
- I mean, yeah.
I would assume every single
officer has secret clearance
at least, okay.
But getting TS/SCI is actually
somewhat more unusual,
costs a lot of money
and actually has quite a bit
of value on the private sector
once you leave the military.
- Yes, I have heard that.
- I will say this, for all
of you who are watching,
if you have a little bit
of classified information
that you're not allowed to tell anyone,
and a civilian just
tells you, oh, it's okay,
I have security clearance, too.
(Devin laughing)
Do not,
do not give them that
classified information.
It's gonna be a bad day for you
if that person does not in fact
have that security clearance.
- [Goose] No, no, ma'am
this is not a good idea.
- [Maverick] Sorry, Goose.
But it's time to buzz the tower.
(jet engine whirring)
(upbeat music)
- Goddamn, this son of a bitch.
- All right, that seems super bad.
- Yeah, as Maverick's defense attorney,
I've gotta say, he
needs to, at this point,
not say anything to anyone
about what just happened,
lock himself into a room
and hope for the best.
- So yeah, what did he just do there?
- A number of crimes.
I mean, honestly, this
is one of those cases
where he could get racked up
on maybe five different counts.
He certainly, willfully disobeyed
the order of a superior
commissioned officer.
(bell chimes)
There's another article at the UCMJ
about drunken or reckless operation
of an aircraft.
(bell chimes)
There's another one,
reckless endangerment.
(bell chimes)
There's another, conduct
unbecoming an officer
and a gentleman.
(bell chimes)
Improperly hazarding an aircraft.
Some of those could
carry the death penalty.
The reality is some of those
would be harder to prove,
some would be easier.
The one that he absolutely just did
is disobeying that order.
And that's a bad, bad thing for him.
- Yeah, it seems like in the military,
you kind of have to follow orders.
- We follow orders or people die.
- You know, it's strongly suggested.
And unfortunately, in the real world,
not only would he get grounded,
he would probably lose his wings entirely
and spend the rest of
his time on his contract,
like filling sandbags
or doing something very
menial in an office.
- Sounds about right.
- That's because every
time you go open the air,
you're unsafe.
I don't like you because you're dangerous.
- That's right.
Iceman.
I am dangerous.
(teeth chatter)
- That's what we call an admission.
And unfortunately for him,
it is absolutely true.
And goes back to some
of the reckless things
that he's been doing this entire time.
Again, as Maverick's defense attorney,
I strongly advise him to remain silent
when it comes to this kind of stuff.
- Okay, so that reminds
me of a certain fan theory
about "Top Gun",
which is that "Top Gun"
is really a love story
between two characters,
not Tom Cruise and Kelly McGillis,
but rather, Tom Cruise's character
and Val Kilmer's character, Iceman.
If, let's say Maverick and
Iceman were not married,
but then decided to
have a relationship with each other,
would that violate any rules of the UCMJ?
- So what it would probably violate
would be a regulation that says
people who are on the same command
cannot have intimate relationships.
Now, if they, because they're
both at the Top Gun school,
you're not allowed to have
an intimate relationship
just because of the way that
that could impact the school,
the command, et cetera.
However, once they're outside of Top Gun,
as long as they're not in the same unit,
they can have the most
wonderful relationship
that they could possibly want.
And I wish them the best.
(Devin laughing)
♪ Take my breath away ♪
- You can be my wing man, anytime.
- You know, funny story,
I actually was a military prosecutor
signed to what is now Marine
Corps Air Station Miramar.
And I watched at least
one pilot get prosecuted.
One pilot got entirely
dismissed from the Marine Corps.
He was a test pilot for an
F-35 and it was for adultery.
He got kicked out for adultery.
- So I mean, that's not a crime (laughs),
for civilians, that's a
crime for service members?
- It absolutely is.
And it is actually a
frighteningly common crime
for service members.
Now it's not enough that you had an affair
when you're married
or you had an affair with
someone who is married.
There has to be something
additional to it.
- Huh.
- It has to be either
prejudicial to good order and discipline,
or have a tendency to
discredit the Armed Forces.
But in adultery cases,
(sighs) they're not that hard to show and-
- Yeah, I mean, so why would adultery
be something that the
military cares about?
- Well, for one, there are
a lot of moralistic prigs
who are in the military,
but the other part of it is,
you really can't have people,
especially in the same chain of command
or on the same base,
who are themselves
married and having affairs
with other people on the base.
- Ah.
- So for example,
let's say that you're a
captain like Maverick,
you're single, but you
decide to have an affair
with someone who's married on the base
and that person is a civilian,
but married to another
officer, for example.
That can cause real tensions
inside of the base, inside of the command.
And that is prejudicial to
good order and discipline
because you're introducing
so much possibility
for anger, recrimination.
It's just something you
want to avoid entirely.
- Sir.
I had Commander Heatherly in my sites.
He saw me move in for the kill.
He then proceeded below the hard deck.
We weren't below 10,000 for
more than a few seconds.
I had the shot.
There was no danger so I took it.
- So here's the problem with this,
what he did by going
underneath the hard deck
was a violation of the regulations.
But also let's talk about what
the hard deck really meant
in this context.
- Yeah, what does that mean?
- The hard deck simulates the ground.
So when he says that he
went beneath the hard deck,
only for a few seconds,
that's like saying in your aircraft,
you went beneath the ground
for a couple seconds.
(Devin laughing)
That hard deck is there
for everyone's safety,
so that you have lots of buffer room
in a training environment.
And for him to just be underneath
it for a couple seconds,
well, you know, I'm sure
the aircraft will be fine
underneath the desert of California
for a couple seconds.
- It's an aircraft and a submarine.
- Yep.
- That's how good we are.
- We're getting there guys.
- The communication ship SS
Layton has become disabled
and has wandered in the foreign territory.
Rescue operation is to
begin within the hour.
Your mission is to give
air support to that rescue.
- So this is kind of a complicated setup.
We're obviously, tensions are high
and there's the possibility of war
or some sort of hostile act here
where we actually are gonna see combat.
Now we have to assume that
what that means in the film
is that this ship has drifted
into what are called territorial waters.
Now, territorial waters for
any country on the ocean,
they extend about 12 miles out.
But because the law of the sea,
there's an exception to that,
which is called innocent passage.
So what innocent passage means is
if another ship goes through
and all they're doing is going to port
or going through those territorial waters
with innocent motives,
then you can't just attack them.
It's not an invasion of the
country or anything like that.
Now what they can do, of course,
is they can police their
territorial waters.
So someone comes in for,
on innocent passage,
you can board them, you can search them.
You can do a variety
of things to make sure
that it is in fact innocent passage.
So the problem is
that while there's innocent
passage in the sea,
there is no such thing as
innocent passage in the air.
The second that a US combat
aircraft goes into the airspace
above another country's
territorial waters,
that could be very clearly
seen as an act of war.
- Oh, well, that complicates
things a lot, I think.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So what you're saying is
that the American planes
are entering into a
zone of danger,
a sort of danger zone.
- (laughing) They are in fact
going into the danger zone.
♪ Danger zone ♪
(Spencer laughing)
(jet engine whirring)
- Goddamn it.
- All right, so we've already talked about
how much of a blatant
violation buzzing the tower is
back in Miramar.
Assuming that they
weren't run out on rail,
what would happen if they
buzzed a tower again,
after being reprimanded the first time?
- Nothing good.
(Devin laughing)
In fact, very, very bad things.
I think it's safe to
say that at this point,
Maverick is not just gonna
be stripped of his wings,
but he's probably gonna get
dismissed from the service.
- And also on top of it,
we're at war now.
This unidentified country has
shot down an American plane.
I think by all reasonable accounts,
that means that we are
at war with this country.
Seems like a really super
bad time to be showboating.
- Absolutely.
And the reality is, I mean,
we do find out slightly later in this film
that this other country
is gonna decide that,
hey, it's no big deal,
but we don't know that right now.
Everyone on this aircraft
carrier has to assume
that we are at war right
now with this country.
And yet, we're doing a fly by.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
That, so, yeah, that seems bad.
- Suboptimal.
(crowd cheering)
(men yelling)
Somewhere, there is a chief
petty officer in the Navy
screaming and sobbing into a pillow.
The fact that we are in war right now,
or at least we have to
assume that we're in war
and the entire deck crew
is abandoning their posts,
running out to celebrate these guys,
when for all we know,
there's a bunch of other MiGs
heading directly for
this aircraft carrier.
I mean, these people need
to be at their posts.
They need to be retro, like
they need to be refueling,
refitting these aircraft.
They need to be getting
combat air patrol out there.
And instead,
they're all just having
the time of their lives.
I don't even know what to say.
- [Devin] Yeah, it looks like
they just won a college football game.
- Yeah, I mean, they definitely
just scored a touchdown.
Unfortunately, we may have
nukes in the other end zone.
- (laughing) All right, Spencer,
now we need to tally all the crimes.
How long is Tom Cruise's
Maverick going to jail?
- Let me put it this way.
If we are in fact at war,
he's probably gonna get the death penalty.
If we're not actually at war,
he's probably gonna get,
oh, let's say about three
to four years in the Brig
and a dismissal from the Armed Forces.
(somber horn music)
- And a $250 fee for not wearing a helmet
while riding motorcycle.
- That really is the knife
that twists, isn't it?
- (sighs) Well, Spencer, you
can be my wing man, anytime.
♪ Take my breath away ♪
- No Devin, you can be mine.
(hands slapping)
(both laughing)
- You two characters are going to Top Gun.
- So the Navy's gonna fire Maverick,
or I guess they might
hang him from a Yard Arm,
but this is America
so he'll probably just
sue to get his job back.
And he could really benefit
from my feature length master
course on Nebula Classes.
It's called "How To Sue Like a Lawyer".
I take you through the
legal process, step-by-step
in a fun and entertaining way.
You know, in case you
ever need to sue someone,
or you're just curious how
that whole thing works.
And not only that,
but I have another class called
"Copyright For Fun and Profit",
explains everything
you ever wanted to know
about copyright and IP,
whether you're a creator
artist or student,
because today's sponsor, Nebula Classes,
is a brand new part of Nebula.
the creator-owned streaming platform
that I'm building with a
bunch of my creator friends.
Every class is insanely well
produced and entertaining.
We fly every creator to New York
to shoot with the entire
Nebula Classes team.
It's a little bit like masterclass
from the creators that you love.
I promise you, you will
get lost in the rabbit hole
of amazing classes
because it's not just my classes,
there are classes from
Thomas Frank on productivity,
Aimee Nolte on jazz improv,
Sam from Wendover, on persuasion
and tons of others.
We have new classes dropping every week
led by your favorite creators
and experts in their field.
And it's not just full length classes,
we're also hosting Nebula talks,
inspirational short form guest lectures,
kinda like TED from the
creators that you love.
And better yet, since
classes is part of Nebula,
you'll also get access
to all of my exclusive
and ad-free content that
I usually release early.
And Nebula has just passed
over 500,000 happily paying customers.
So if you're one of the few people
that hasn't already signed up,
now is your chance to discover
the greatest collection
of thought-provoking videos on the planet.
And you'll find new things
to discover every day.
And you can watch all of this great stuff
just about anywhere with your iPhone,
iPad, Android, Android TV,
Apple TV, and Roku apps.
And best of all, if you're
already a Nebulous subscriber,
upgrading to classes is
just an extra $5 per month.
And if you're signing
up for the first time,
the whole thing is only $10 per month
or $100 per year.
But for a limited time,
if you go to Nebulaclasses.com/legaleagle
or click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description,
there's a special discount of 20% off.
The easiest thing to do is click
on the link that's on screen right now
to access the amazing Nebula Classes.
Those funds go directly to the creators
and funds even more amazing content.
Again, just click on the
link that's on screen
or in the description to see
why Nebula Classes rocks.
And while you're there,
click on this other link
for all of my other videos
or I'll see you in court.